your brothers and sisters in the slum
nap from Norway are establishing a
Masjid a dawa Center this Center this
Masjid this educational institution will
act like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah
azzawajal will give you even more you
debate you both debate at homosexuality
and you've talked to a lot of gay people
in your videos so yeah like what is that
what is Islam say about that and and how
do you guys view that in the modern day
I think that you know with homosexuality
obviously Islam forbids uh like
homosexuality as a practice not as a not
as a feeling because no one is you can
say someone is not in control of how
they feel in some cases and we accept
that so someone feels in a certain way
then it's forbidden to act upon it in
like in a penetrative way if you're a
man or so I have sex with another man
and so on now Islam forbids this
uh it doesn't mean that if someone
practices it by the way they become an
ex-muslim or that they leave Islam or
they excommunicate they're still within
the folders it's just seen as a major
sin there is obviously no therefore when
you say a marriage I say no are there a
number of hierarchy of sins okay yeah so
where would that rank high very high
like in one of the schools of Islam he
says up there with murder something wow
yeah it's very well what about manchine
on his wife or vice versa that's that's
a major scene as well yeah yeah so if a
man cheats on his wife it's a major sin
like is that on the same level yeah yeah
100 man both there are things that in
Islam that main people will not consider
it like for example usury like interest
getting a loan from the bank yes you
know things like that I've seen as major
sins on that kind of level as well so
there is a hierarchy that we have going
on which maybe some Outsiders when they
look at it they'll find it a bit strange
but having said that the argument we put
forward about homosexuality is this is
that there's two there's two major like
ethical Pathways in Western ethics yeah
you have something called utilitarianism
and you have something called
deontological ethics utilitarianism was
spearheaded by someone called Jeremy
Bentham and that was taken on board by
John Stuart Mill and it's being kind of
embedded into what is referred to in our
social liberalism yeah and the idea is
really it's the harm principle which is
that you can do whatever you want so
long as you don't have anybody else
and
we're trying to achieve the greatest
good for the greatest number of people
so that's one way of looking at morality
yeah that is the way of John Stuart Mill
and it's pretty much accepted now in
Western Society so when I say the
liberal ethic is dominant in the west
I'm talking about these Notions that you
can do whatever you want so long as you
don't have anyone else deontological
ethics is spearheaded by someone called
Emmanuel Kant and what he says is that
what he says is basically that there are
some things which will always be
categorically wrong
and uh if you imagine all of society
doing it uh and it leads to some kind of
impossibility that that thing is wrong
so for example he would say lying is
always wrong and there's no
justification even if death resulted as
a result of it the lying is always wrong
these are two ways of looking at it now
these are the two ways that moral
philosophers and ethicists in the west
have looked at the I'm saying on both
ways homosexuality as a practice there
is aspersion cast on the morality of it
I'll explain how
if we say from a deontological
perspective that the things that if they
were conducted by everybody that the
society would not continue or that
there'll be the impossibility in uh in
that sense
I either it was refer to as a
categorical imperative that's why
Emmanuel Cancer lying is wrong because
if everyone did it we wouldn't be able
to function as Society so suicide is
wrong because if everyone did it we
wouldn't be able to function there'll be
death then buy the same token or buy the
same logic then homosexuality would be
wrong because if everyone did it then so
that's the ontological route the more
the more popular route which is the
utilitarian route or the if you like the
liberal route now which is the greatest
good for the great stuff so long as
you're not harming anybody else we would
say there's actually aspersion cost
First of all how do you prove that the
harm principle is true as is there a
scientific way that you've come to to
prove that the harm principle is true
secondly
uh if even if we implemented the hum
principle on homosexuality the question
would be
uh could you make an argumentative case
that it actually harms more people by
way of disease or by way of contraction
of this or as we know from the NHS that
homosexual sex is more likely to spread
certain diseases and so on so could you
make a communitarian argument against
homosexual practice we would argue yes
you can and even if you argue on the on
the basis of families and so on we were
talking about the stability of certain
families
you could I would postulate and I would
argue that actually all of the data
almost without exception has shown that
homosexual relationships man man woman
woman
disadvantages the children more than a
nuclear family in this in what sense in
the sense of the child is more likely to
be to include themselves in delinquency
the educational levels more uh less
thing they're more likely to have
psychological pathology and so on so
even on a utilitarian basis we would say
that the traditional family setup is
superior
to
um the homosexual uh Lifestyle on those
two grounds if you're looking at even
from the Western lens we're not even
saying from the Islamic lens because all
we have to say is that God said so but
we're not going down that I'm saying
that if you look at a utilitarian lens
or from a deontological lens both would
point to the same reality but do you
think you're reverse engineering a
little bit of this and trying to sort of
make it more palatable for
you know when you're getting challenged
on it a sort of thing all I'm doing is
I'm using the ethics which are seen as
the most Superior ethics in the west to
show you that even based on those ethics
that you can make a argumentative case
against the practice of homosexuality
your brothers
and slam net from Norway are
establishing
this educational institution will act
like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah
azzawajal will give you even